The Joe Rogan Experience we never told
Joe about the center of the world we
passed in Arizona oh okay
Arizona that's the lettuce capital of
uh Arizona in case you're wondering
known for lettuce and dates mostly on
New Year's Eve they drop lettuce like a
head of lettuce like a ball anyways that
decides that's a side story but so we
went to Yuma Arizona and on the way back
um we're driving by and there's like
we're in the middle of the desert and we
look and there's just like this
staircase that goes to nowhere
and like I see it in the middle of the
desert I see it and Kim sees it and
we're both like we get this really bad
weird feeling and we're like we need to
go back and like find out what that is
so we turn this movie yeah well we
thought it was a movie too we made we
actually we go back and we we go back
and we find this town can you show the
whole town from like all the Felicity
how many drunks have died there yeah no
it is this is what we went to this is
what we see in the middle of nowhere
and it's called the center of the world
and uh we did a tour we did a tour
because we're like well this is a movie
we should film some [__] because I was
like let's go take a tour it's like an
eight mile city called Felicity and only
a population of seven or something like
that and it's definitely a cult yes but
he says okay so he so in the steps we
looked up those stairs that go to
Nowhere from the Eiffel Tower yeah
this is in Arizona this is in Arizona
and this really rich guy he's a uh what
is it baller he's a baller was a
Rothschild a Rothschild he bought this
town of Felicity and named it after his
wife Felicity wait is this real who we
think we ran into can we make sure that
this is real we we visited we have to
check out there this is yeah this is the
website
we get there there's 22 there's 22 we
made a scary movie trailer out of it
I'll send it to Jamie send it to Jamie
so we can show we go for tours of this
place oh we did a tour we did a tour of
fine why they tried to get us into this
cult they put us in this pyramid and
they made us to make a wish they made us
try to get they tried to get us in the
center of the pyramid in the center of
the thing put our foot in the middle
save this thing and make a wish and then
sign a contract and I was like and we're
like I'm not doing that and she was like
well it's the only part of the tour you
have to do and they go to do the tour
and that's when we said we don't want to
do the tour anymore we're going to leave
and she was pissed and then they said
she goes this right here is the center
of the world
no do you have
um
no but she's you got her on video saying
this dude we have this lady covering her
eyes yeah don't put that up because
that'll be a problem what what like a
video of her that she doesn't want up
she's covering her face I mean you can't
see your face but it's like you turn and
she's in the corner of a gift shop it's
this old lady it has to be Felicity
herself oh my God they're all in weird
what do you think is going on okay so
basically so this is from your
experience of being there from our
experience being there
are you sober at the time yes yes why
why were we sober yeah we're driving
from Arizona
you didn't know what you're gonna find
we just did a show
it was early in the morning but once you
knew you had a tour
once we saw it and we're like because
the staircase you can see it from so far
away and then you see the pyramid and
you're like something is going on here
20 cars in the parking lot no people you
guys are exactly what they're looking
for yeah oh my gosh girls driving by
yourself so they're big sunglasses just
show up like God brought me here
it was a sign it was 2 222 and we had I
saw the staircase and then when I
climbed off and I saw the city I was
like OMG I'm home there's a post office
there but there's only 10 people that
live in in the town there's a cop that
lives there who went there to
investigate what was going on and then
never left and never left wow and then
he lives there now I like to watch
center of the world dude it was an eerie
energy
maybe it's not maybe they're just
playing golf and [__] listening old
records no how do you know because when
you got went there you know well yeah
you have a sixth sense when it's a call
you feel it in your body we had to get
the [__] out of there quickly after we
got locked in the pyramid oh I said hey
it's time to go mama get in the car
Mommy and Mama are leaving
it was just saying that we were there we
and that was the exact time that we were
at the center of the world
and you were agreeing that that was the
center of the world yeah yeah so they're
getting data and how many people agree
they took our name yeah and then we're
like can we film and she's like yeah and
then we can say nice things you're not
going to say anything bad are you she
like threatened us
anyway it just seems weird that no one
has been there before and filmed it it
might not exist
we go back it's gone yeah this is
there's dust look at it the chapel oh
and it has this arm pointing to the
temple yeah it has this thing
so what do you think they're up to uh
just living their own little farm you
see it it points right to the center of
the uh the way they want to live up
there I think it's like a really rich
guy well the guy has a crazy story so
that what is that his like family tree
what will you just point to
what is this like oh they do this it's
like the history they have like it's
called like the history of the world no
it's the history of something and they
have like things that mattered to him
major events in history of humanity yeah
and the guy who came to do that on the
granite the guy came to do that from
Europe on the granite and he never he
never went back to his family afterwards
yeah this sounds like a cool place but
you guys are selling it that it seems
like everybody she's alive still Jacques
yeah Jacques he used to he was the first
inventor of the parachute or something
like that oh yeah he was a parachute
there's a parachute in World War II he's
like [__] this this is perfect I'm
staying here he's he's a very complex
man a parachuter that bought a pyramid
and put the Eiffel Tower stairs in the
middle of the and he made himself mayor
of the town that he found it beautiful
that's the way to do it yeah Shanksville
welcome to Shane's Hometown there's
eight people in it yeah and me and
Shane's coming by
God so you think they give tours to make
new friends
yeah new friends yeah they took a part
of our energy and soul we left with a
migraine is what we're saying something
was up yeah they offered to her so
anybody can go to this I think try your
own conclusions who knows they'll never
leave just like all these other Happy
People yes you guys maybe it is
it's just what a strange thing to do it
was weird start of town in the middle of
the desert and say it's the center of
the world self-proclaimed center of the
world actually is that what they say
does it say it on their website that
it's the center of the world oh yeah I'm
trying to dig into I'm trying to find
yeah like he also made it okay so before
he made the center of the world he wrote
a children's book about a dragon called
center of the world and then he said and
and he did the children's book first
because he said you know like when you
make up a story you can create whatever
you want and No One's Gonna question it
so he made like this whole story about
the center of the world it was like a
children's book and then he went ahead
and made the center of the world
hmm or he's a prophet or he's a oh he's
right and it is the center of the world
what if he is the center of the world
trust me like what if it's like it ain't
the center of the world
we went it's Yuma
Buddha slash Jesus characters it comes
along and everybody questions oh my God
he was the guy yeah the history for
Jesus to pick the human world that's a
good spot yeah
you know
imagine getting married at the center of
the world why wouldn't you you're the
center of the universe
it's perfect place to get married I'm
not giving chocolate there's the
children's book oh the good Dragon at
the center of the world so this dude is
like obsessed with Hollow Earth it's a
real Theory
do you know that they found more more
water under the ocean under the Earth's
surface he wanted us to step
that is the very center of the world but
I know that it actually is
no no
100 they checked and uh that's it in the
Tupperware
Arizona even though top is here and it's
like this poles whatever that's the
senator yeah that's the center
everywhere you are is a center yeah it's
a globe you [__] [__] I guess
you're right it's not like a total real
right it's a spheroid well that was his
whole point was that anywhere could be
so he was picking the spot yeah suck it
you're like this is actually you don't
get to pick yeah scientists have to pick
if they do decide what the center is
it's going to be a lot of very [__]
smart people with like some serious
equipment it's going to take a long time
it's gonna have to sort it through not a
rich parachuter it's the center is in
the lava you [__] I believe in the
center you got to go to the center it's
you're on the surface like saying that
you're on the edge of the world you
literally can't be the center of the
world no you're on the corner of the
world inside the hole but maybe they're
right about it being like the spot maybe
they're right if it's flat you never
know there's a center